card trap it's worse than the paycheck
to paycheck cycle because instead of
just getting paid spending your money
and then having to get paid again you
are getting paid and throwing most of
that money at your credit card to try to
get the balance down then running out of
money and then having to use the credit
card to pay for things again it's like
you're standing in a bog just covered in
leeches and every time you try to pull
some leeches off they attach in other
places why don't you step out of the bog
and then remove the leeches
[Music]
so I want you to pay just the minimum
payment on your credit card this month
let most of your paycheck stay in your
checking account and use your debit card
to pay for everything this month instead
of using their credit card to pay for
anything then at the end of the month
you can get a sense of how much you can
actually sustainably put towards the
credit card from each paycheck while
still covering your bills and paying for
some Joy advanced mode is go make a
budget so that you can actually stick to
it